In this day and age, parallelism has
become fundamental to computer systems. Any general purpose
CPU chip, has multiple cores in it.
Every general purpose operating system is designed to
take advantage of such hardware parallelism. In
this unit, we will study the basic algorithms
for synchronization, communication, and scheduling, in a
shared memory multiprocessor. Leading up to the structure
of the operating system for parallel machines.
We'll start today's lecture with a discussion
of the model of a parallel machine. A shared memory multi-processor, or a shared
memory machine we can think of three
different structures for this shared memory machine.
The first structure is what we call a dance hall architecture and a dance
hall architecture is one in which you have CPUs on
one side and the memory on the other side of an
interconnection network and let me say something that is common
to all the three structures that I'm going to describe to
you. The common things are that in every one of
these structures, there's going to be CPUs and there going to be memory,
and there's going to be an interconnection network. And the key
thing is it's a shared memory machine. What that means is
that the entire address space defined by the memories is
accessible from any of the CPUs. So that's one common
thing that you see in all the three styles that
I'm going to talk to you about. And in addition to that,
you'll see that there is a cache that is associated
with each of these CPUs. So there's a Dance Hall
Architecture. And the next style is what is called an
SMP architecture, or a Symmetric multiprocessor. Here what you see is
the interconnection network hat I showed you from the
dance hall architecture. I simplified it considerably, showing a
simple bus. A system bus that connects all the
CPU's to talk to the main memory. And and
it is symmetric because the access time from any
of the CPUs to memory is the same. And
that's the idea of the system bus that allows
all of these CPUs to talk to the main memory.
The other thing that you'll notice that I already
mentioned is that every CPU comes equipped with a
cache and we'll talk more about the shared memory
machine, the caches in a minute. So the third style
of architecture is what is called a distributor shared
memory architecture. So in this distributor shared memory architecture what
you have, or DSM for short, is that. You
have memory and a piece of memory that is associated
with each CPU. At the same time each CPU is able to access all of
the memories through the interconnection network. It
is just that the access to memory that
is close to this guy is going to be obviously faster than trying to access
memory that is farther from here that
has to be accessed from the interconnection network.